es un fenómeno tradicional del
primero son la selección es un poco
complicada y que son a dos vueltas
un 50 por ciento de los votos y luego en
la segunda vuelta pasan solamente los
dos más votados entonces eso desmotiva a
muchas personas también son unas
elecciones que están vinculadas desde el
año 2001 a las presidenciales vienen
apenas pocas semanas después por lo
tanto la gente está cansada y muchos no
van
en general fue una elección presidencial
que movilizó poco se vio eclipsada por
el conflicto ucraniano que es lo mismo
que ha pasado con estas
y poco interés y también ustedes lo
decían el presidente manuel macro no fue
electo sobre todo por un gran voto de
rechazo a la extrema derecha en el año
2017 vi a mucha gente que quería venir a
votar para apoyarlo sin embargo esta vez
esa motivación parece menor la gran
sorpresa podría ser la coalición de
izquierda de la nube que podría
movilizar a más electorado sin embargo
como decía anteriormente son los jóvenes
y las clases populares los que
tradicionalmente votan menos en estas
elecciones que justamente son el
electorado fuerte de izquierda a francés